je croyais des trucs tellement débile
quand j'étais gamin j'aimerais
j'aimerais tellement remonté le temps me
rencontrer petit et m'expliquer à quel
point j'étais con cyprien je suis toi
dans le futur oui j'ai deux pêcheurs non
pompiers volontaires non tu vas devenir
youtuber tu vas faire des vidéos sur
internet des vidéos qui vont s'afficher
sur pleins d'ordinateurs mais c'est
génial dans le futur ya des voitures qui
va là non on peut supporter non faut que
je te dise le logo carrefour c'est pas
un visage penché bas si on peut
clairement voir les deux yeux non c'est
assez dans un losange
ah oui et celui de la caisse d'epargne
c'est pas un logo abstrait c'est un
écureuil
allez salut
ah oui michael jackson est mort quand
j'étais petit je croyais que deux dans
la catégorie orthographe
quand j'étais petit je croyais que l'eau
de toilette c'était de l'eau des
toilettes
excuse moi mais vous pu la merde
merci bonne journée quand j'étais petit
je crois que dans les drogueries on
vendait de la drogue
du coup dans ma tête je pensais la
drogue c'était illégal et en même temps
que légal police vous vendez la drogue
ici un oui très bien continuer comme ça
aujourd'hui vous voulez du crack d'amd
quand j'étais petit je croyais que le
cochon d'inde
c'était un cochon d'inde est en fait en
fait non ce ne rien avoir en même temps
je sais pas qui a décidé que cet animal
allait être un cochon un gros hamster la
limite quand j'étais petit je croyais
que pendant l'accouchement perdre les
eaux c'était perdre les eaux ce qui
n'était pas normal bon écoute et
l'accouchement s'est bien passé l'enfant
va bien par contre on n'a perdu que deux
tibias voilà c'est pour ça que je tiens
plus debout
je veux la retrouver elle était juste
tombé dans la catégorie j'étais super
content quand j'étais petit je croyais
que quand mes parents rouler la nuit la
lune nous suivaient
[Musique]
à droite un endroit droite on est suivi
quand j'étais petit je jouais à cache
cache
attention je crois qu'il suffisait que
je me cache les yeux pour qu'on ne voit
plus en fait on me voit encore quand je
crois quand j'étais petit je croyais que
mes jouets étaient vivants la nuit oui
comme dans toy story oui j'ai été très
influençable c'est vrai je sais pas je
le dire à personne
ça restera un droit sacré ok ça marche
quand j'étais petit je trouvais que ceux
qui n'avaient pas la télévision était
carrément bizarre maintenant c'est ce
qui la regarde que je trouve ce loup
quand j'étais petit je faisais vachement
gaffe au petit logo en bas à droite -
dans les films à la télévision
par exemple quand j'avais 9 ans et demi
et je regardais un film déconseillé aux
moins de 10 ans je me sentais comme un
hors-la-loi bon en vrai je regrette un
petit peu aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
que c'est plus trop d'actualité pour mes
8 ans j'ai demandé que l'avenue ti quand
j'étais petit j'ai peur de faire
dépasser mes pieds du lit ce que je
croyais qu'il y avait un monstre caché
sous mon lit qu'ils allaient me les
attraper comme ça comme si les monstres
se disait à mme a fait plier dépasse
plus comment je peux faire maintenant
mais bien baisés pourrait sortir je
pourrais l'attraper mais non il a rangé
ses merdes et toi tu croyais quoi quand
tu étais petit un lâche 1 comme ah oui
vous êtes 3 millions fans sur ma page
facebook
c
incroyable merci beaucoup tu veux être
mon meilleur ami abonne toi
la base virale vps a été mis à plat les
parties tout seul frère ça marche bien
ça marche bien et sa part validé votre
prénom
c'est un bagel chez red bull